the old montauk it's gone
if you don't put our money into the
future we might as well just just lay
down in the middle of the road and let
the summer people drive all over us it's
basically what we're doing here
montauk
on the far end of new york's long island
has a well-earned reputation as a summer
retreat for new york's elite but as that
clip from the showtime series the affair
shows it's also long been home to
working class residents who live there
year round that contrast is the setting
for a tragic tale told in a new book and
anthony mason is here with the story
anthony good morning good morning and
the lost boys of montauk published by
simon schuster a division of viacom cbs
author amanda fairbanks traces the
evolution of eastern long island from a
land of blue-collar fishing villages to
what it's become today at the heart of
her story are four commercial fishermen
from vastly different backgrounds who
shared a tragic fate lost at sea
together more than 30 years ago
so the wind blown would have come out
from here yes exactly and this would
have been probably her fourth or fifth
on
voyage
cold march day in 1984 a 65-foot fishing
trawler headed out of montauk harbor
the wind blown was charting a course to
catch tile fish heading from the tip of
long island
miles offshore out near the continental
shelf
but after a week at sea author amanda
fairbanks says
an ominous storm stirred suddenly in the
atlantic what was the weather out here
like that day
it was literally an unforecasted
hurricane
the east coast of the united states is
reeling today from the biggest storm in
recent history the freak nor'easter
would cause a freighter to run aground
on cape cod
and topple the nantucket lighthouse
the crew of the windblown met an even
darker fate there was never a mayday
call
they just vanished
on board were captain mike stedman a
father of three he was the son of a
harvard educated united nations diplomat
dave connick the 22 year old son of a
prominent new york lawyer
mike vigilant a 19 year old doc rat
whose father had died at sea in a
fishing accident
and scott clark
at 18. he was the youngest he was the
youngest
in fairbanks book they are the lost boys
of montauk
they were last had radio contact about a
dozen miles
from montauk point off the lighthouse
here off the lighthouse in between block
island and the lighthouse that's where
captain mike put his location on the
morning of march 29 1984. and he sounded
quite panicked and worried
and he told his friend to please tell
mary his wife that he loved her
and that was the last time that anyone
would ever hear his voice again
fishermen feared lost the east hampton
star reported in a front page story
after the storm so it says they found a
life raft
paddles described with the name of the
wind blown clothing
debris the boat's plywood wheel house
but no sign of the men
or the boat steel hull right
how big a deal was it when that boat
disappeared
the wind blown's loss was
paralyzing david rattray is the editor
of the east hampton star for those of us
who grew up during that time you know if
you go out around montauk point
you think about it
you know
out at the end of long island beyond the
glitzy hamptons
montauk has long been a commercial
fishing hub
how hard did that hit this town they
were die hard strong
eager
young fisherman that wanted to make an
honest living yeah
the town took it hard henry uline went
out to search for the missing crew back
in 84. you knew captain mike yes
what kind of guy was he
excellent fisherman yeah not a dead
devil not one to take chances yeah
certainly not stupid
he had a lesser opinion of the wind
blown itself it was just
top heavy
originally built as the party boat
captain scotty mike stedman had bought
it in texas and sailed it to montauk
where he modified it this is the boat's
propeller yes this was the propeller
morgan mcgivern has some rare artifacts
this is the wind blown a month before it
sank
this is the only picture of the boat
that anyone knows of yeah mcgivern was
friends with captain mike and dave
connick is it something you think about
a lot i do yeah yeah
dave was your best friend uh dave was my
closest friend as a child and he took to
fishing you know like a disease and
then he uh was fishing
pretty much all the time he was an
adventurer he occasionally used to climb
to the on
on stand on the chimney right up the
side of the house on the house yeah
hundreds would turn out for the memorial
service at most holy trinity church in
east hampton
donovan's song atlantis was played at
its conclusion
[Music]
for the families the grief would be
overwhelming and
enduring mud vigilant continued to
believe her son was alive
she did and and donna llewellyn did too
she had worked for twa airlines
and would spend the latter part of her
life
traveling to south america or the
caribbean or florida or getting in her
car and taking a road trip in hopes of
finding her son and putting up signs
missing signs for her son and i'll never
you know as a mother i'll never i'll
never stop thinking about that
in 1999 a monument to lost sailors was
unveiled on montauk point
the wind blowns crew is named on it
but the boat itself is still out there
somewhere you talked about the vanishing
the vanishing aspect and i think the
wreck has so much to do with the
vanishing aspect because there is this
lack of closure there the bodies were
never located the whole of the boat was
never found people around here still
think about that day it crosses my mind
whenever i walk down this dock and if
it's windy i always think of that day
and i miss mike
but it's
life